revista de prensa en directo américa de
france a 24 rosa pérez o más de ella nos
acompaña en este estudio en esta mesa de
trabajo rosa jubilado de platino la
reina isabel segunda vamos a hablar
entonces de la prensa británica que dice
the times the daily telegraph the
independent the gardian mejor dicho que
está pasando con todo este jubileo y
como lo resalta la prensa pues a raúl
como comprenderás sobre todo no la
prensa británica hoy dedica sus portadas
a estos a 70 años de reinado de isabel
segunda si bien es verdad que digamos en
muchas portadas la fotografía de la
reina rivaliza bastante con la de amber
hearn no después de la sentencia de ayer
pero bueno eso es completamente otro
tema empezamos por the times que dice la
reina agradece a la nación en su mensaje
de jubileo pues por la amabilidad y el
cariño no esta popularidad que digamos
que tiene entre la población del reino
unido o según quien recordemos que
asumió el trono el 2 de junio de 1953
digamos ahora se cumplen 70 años de esa
coronación pero qué digamos ella se
convirtió en reina pues un año antes por
otro lado the daily telegraph también ha
citado una parte del mensaje que dirigió
a la nación miramos al futuro con
confianza y entusiasmo y de independents
tiene un ángulo pues muy distinto
digamos de informar sobre este jubileo
porque lo que titula the independent es
el nh ese que recordemos es el servicio
nacional de salud se prepara para el
caos del fin de semana de jubileo en aie
que son a los departamentos de
accidentes y emergencias médicas el
profesional del sistema los
profesionales del sistema de salud
británicos alertan que ya de por sí pues
hay una escasez de personal médico y que
se espera que estos cuatro días de
celebraciones pues sobrepasen las
capacidades de estos departamentos de
emergencia médica sobre todo por temas
hay accidentes relacionados con el
consumo de alcohol y por otro lado the
gardian pues vemos como dice 70 cosas
que no sabes sobre los 70 años de
reinado de isabel segunda hemos
seleccionado sólo algo unas de estas 70
pero raúl un dato curioso que nos da y
es que tras la muerte de la princesa
diana isabel segunda fue muy criticada
por mostrarse aparentemente insensible
ante pues ese incidente y en ese momento
sólo el 38 por ciento de los británicos
consideraban que la monarquía iba a
sobrevivir a ese momento the gardian
también señala en los múltiples planos
no planes que están en manos del
gobierno del buckingham palace y también
de la bbc- para cuando fallezca isabel
segunda este plan que tiene pues el
nombre en clave de la torre de londres
ha caído y también indica the gardian
que la mayoría de escenarios planteados
pues se suponen que la reina moreira de
una enfermedad y por otro lado a nivel
irónico un poco pues humorístico the
gardian te da algunos consejos por si
eres republicano como sé sobrevivir a
estas festividades dice hay lugares
todavía en reino unido que no tienen
pues conexión 34 ni 5g el puente de
londres acá y yo creo que es así rosa no
no la tarde allí tenemos que ir
a
cada miembro de la familia real tiene su
su figura no soy su infraestructura como
un hombre clave
pues en un supuesto escenario de muerte
bueno eso lo tenemos pendiente en el
tintero periódicos de irlanda del norte
de rosa exactamente hemos cogido tanto
el belfast telegraph como el irish news
que por un lado representan una
corriente más unionista y por otro lado
una corriente más republicana no de las
corrientes políticas de irlanda del
norte y vemos a que ambos destacan pues
la carta que envió michelle o neill la
primera ministra o ministra principal
electa de irlanda del norte a isabel 2a
recordemos que michelle o neill es la
líder de pues el sinn fein el partido
por excelencia
independentista de irlanda del norte y
en su momento el brazo político del ira
y pues en esta carta la líder
republicana independentista de irlanda
del norte expresa a isabel segunda su
estima y respeto y también le dice que
se compromete a aprovechar todas las
oportunidades para reforzar nuestros
lazos de amistad y renovar nuestro
espíritu de cooperación vamos ahora a
ver qué dice la bbc hay un tono especial
no por supuesto por supuesto pero
decenas de artículos a los que la bebé
se dedica a este día no y por un lado
pues para señalar algunos de los
titulares dice isabel segunda por
dressing y es que no sé si tú has
pensado en esto raúl pero esta mujer es
una de las más fotografiadas de la
historia sí y pues digamos definido lo
que significa vestirse como una reina
también dan detalles de los actos de
esta festividad como que hay 70 aviones
implicados en esta en esta ceremonia
también titula una transición silenciosa
ha empezado hacia el príncipe carlos y
también pero ha dedicado un especial
pues que es un interactivo digamos muy
entretenido al que pues nos hemos
querido enfocar que dice el increíble
cambio que ha visto la reina pues de
1952 hasta 2022 digamos que la
introducción a este especial interactivo
es bastante monárquico no porque dice el
reino unido de hecho el mundo entero no
raúl ha experimentado un gran cambio
social científico y tecnológico en los
últimos 70 años pero la reina ha
permanecido como una presencia
estabilizadora y pues ha enseñado alguno
de los cambios no que ha visto el mundo
en estos 70 años por un lado pues desde
el principio de la era espacial a los
planes de colonizar marte imagen marte
perdón con la llegada del hombre a la
luna en 1969 por otro lado pues desde
que las televisiones entraron a las
casas pues hasta la realidad virtual
recordemos que la coronación de isabel
segunda fue retransmitida pues a través
de las televisiones a pesar de la
oposición de churchill el primer
ministro de reino unido en ese momento
que lo consideraba pues una
vulgarización de la monarquía pero
finalmente tuvo muchísima audiencia por
otro lado desde el nacimiento del rock
and roll a la música en 'streaming' con
la irrupción de internet del movimiento
por los derechos civiles al black lies
es mater de la a la nueva invasión rusa
de ucrania o de la despenalización de la
homosexualidad en
1967 en el reino unido al primer
matrimonio igualitario celebrado en 2014
ella estaba realizando rosa para que no
quede una duda al aire si es en efecto
el puente de londres ha caído es
operativo para cuando la monarca
fallezca ahora que dicen las portadas en
la commonwealth fue amos el sitio en
morning herald de australia pues
recordemos que pues en australia todavía
la jefa del estado es isabel segunda y
precisamente este medio el sydney
morning herald titula larga vida a la
reina pero traigan la república y dice
que esta última semana evidencia pues la
compleja posición y a veces
contradictoria que tiene australia
respecto a la puesta familia real
británica dice el respeto por la reina
nunca ha sido mayor en australia pero
ese momento ya de dirigirse hacia la
república como pretende pues el
actual gobierno no recién electo y es
que según los sondeos de este mismo
medio el 38 por ciento de los
australianos preferiría la república un
30 por ciento la monarquía mientras 34
por ciento de indecisos bueno vamos a
ver recordemos que en 2021 fue barbados
el último pues el país que era parte de
la monarquía británica y que se
convirtió en una república y bueno este
medio como decíamos no apoya esta prensa
de transición a la república de
australia esta editorial de sistema
original que no está muy distante a lo
mejor también a lo que quisieran en
españa pero no vamos a entrar en
terrenos pantanosos que dicen en canadá
pues hemos seleccionado la digamos
visión opuesta totalmente con el
national post de canadá y vemos que
dedica no la foto principal de su
portada a este reino unido empieza la
fiesta pero hay una opinión también que
acompaña esta fotografía de william
watson que dice las ventajas de tener
una monarca como jefa de estado dice yo
cuando era joven también era puede ser
republicano pero con el tiempo me he
dado cuenta me ha dado cuenta de la
estabilidad y la unidad que proporciona
la monarquía británica